look what we have in the studio today
the brand new M3 iMac in pink and the
new space black M3 Max MacBook Pro let's
unbox I think we're going to unbox the
MacBook
first okay ready oh I'm excited so this
has 48 gigs of RAM which you can spec it
up to 128 this is the M3 Max chip with a
1 TB solid state drive which you can
spec up to 8 tab this is the 16-in
version but I order the 14in so I'm
excited to see the 16-in space
black
here it
is no no no smell but that's all
right this is like a heavier
paper wow oh man check this
out it looks so
good it's wild how much bigger this is
than the 14in since I've been using that
for the past year so here it is compared
to the 14in space gray and honestly I
forgot which color MacBook 14in I
ordered so I had to look it up just to
make sure because these two next to each
other this looks silver to me I never
realized how light the space gray was
now in comparison to the space black
this is so much darker now on the new
space black they did a new anodization
process because the midnight MacBook
airs definitely had some fingerprint
issues whereas this one so far I don't
know it looks pretty good it doesn't
feel any different it feels the same
here's the new mag safe cable which is
also in a space black color which I
love wow it's wild like it matches
almost perfectly excited to get this set
up but first we have to unbox the
iMac here she is it's so light also I
got some accessories here power cable
other power cable a pink sticker we've
got the color matched keyboard cable
trackpad and Magic
Mouse here it is the big
unveiling I mean even though I've
already unboxed this once like it is
just so beautiful like the attention to
detail just this beautiful refle
collection oh it's so
pretty shall we peep the accessories
now first things first we have
a lightning cable the accessories are
not yet USBC which is kind of
interesting since we're kind of going
for the full move to USBC so this still
is a braided lightning cable for all of
the accessories that are still lightning
plus lightning still is really great so
I mean no shame here's our Mouse matches
it
beautifully power adapter color matched
braided cable I just love that
everything matches it's so so pretty
fullsize
keyboard that's
nice and last but not least we've got a
trackpad this looks so nice in the whes
look how great everything looks all
together all of the
accessories and the iMac you look great
now that we have both computers unboxed
let's go get them all set up and check
them
out so here they are these are the
latest versions of the MacBook Pro and
the iMac now obviously the main change
with these Macs is the introduction of
the new M3 chips so no new hardware
updates aside from a slightly new
anodized finish on the space black
MacBook Pro to reduce fingerprints now I
think some of us are May maybe hoping
for some new colors in the iMac lineup
or some kind of change but for me I'm
obviously going to go with the pink
anyway so whatever now the previous
version of the iMac only had the M1 chip
so now with the M3 it's going to have
basically double the Speed and
Performance and it still starts at only
$12.99 that's pretty cool and of course
it still has the awesome 4.5k R display
Wi-Fi 6E support built-in webcam color
match peripherals and everything else
that we love about the iMac this does
only come in the M3 configurations so
you aren't able to update it to the Pro
or the max just the M3 but I'm probably
most excited about this new Macbook Pro
because I do travel so much and this is
my main computer now both the 14in and
16-in models now come with the M3 chip
with this entry level 14in starting at
just 1599 and with the M3 Pro and the M3
Max you can now get up to 128 gigs of
memory that is pretty wild and again I
am obsessed with this new space black
finish it is so clean so we're going to
test out both of these we're going to
start with the iMac I'm going to do some
gaming do some editing and then I'm
going to set up my MacBook Pro at my
editing station where I do all of my
work I've got the iMac all set up now
the newest Mac OS is Mac OS syoma and
there are some changes the first thing
that you're going to notice is this new
login screen you'll see down here you've
got your login name where you enter your
user ID or password or just touch ID and
it logs you in automatically something
else that's cool are these new
interactive desktops I went and just got
this super basic pink background to
match the new Mac book this is the hello
metallic pink you can download all these
different Landscapes so this is the
standard one this is the Sonoma Horizon
which is really pretty this doesn't feel
like a maish desktop background which is
why I changed that metallic pink but
there's a few other ones here's another
background let's see what it looks like
as the screen saver these are so awesome
because they're animated like this is
It's So trippy like this is a drone shot
I wonder how far it goes but the
animation looks really cool and it ties
right into the lock screen so when you
log in so I'm going to log in and you'll
see that this transitions from the
screen saver to your desktop with a very
subtle animation it's super subtle but I
love the attention to detail there's so
many different ones but for the sake of
this video I'm going to switch back to
this hello metallic pink something else
new is you can now add widgets to your
desktop now a lot of these features I
don't usually ever use but it is kind of
cool that you do have the ability to
just drag these widgets now right on to
the desktop so I've got the weather here
I'm going to add my
calendar I'm just going to add
everything here just as an example there
they are so there we have our widgets
right on the desktop and if I want to
click into some news I can do that or I
can click into the weather and get more
weather information so it is cool when
you go into the app these kind of gray
out but when you click back to the
desktop they automatically are activated
again another New Sonoma feature is
these hand gestures that you can make
that will then trigger an effect so I'm
just going to use photo photo booth but
these will transfer over to zoom and any
other video conferencing software that
supports it so I'm just going to pop
into the photo booth to give you a
little example of this now the first one
is I'm going to make some hearts here
with making the little heart sign got a
thumbs up we'll give you a thumbs up and
a thumbs down will surprise we'll give
you a thumbs down two thumbs
down it's a little storm it's so great
PE sign with one hand we'll get some
balloons peace signed with two hands
confetti if we do a rock on symbol we'll
get some
lasers I haven't used photo booth like
this since like 2006 this is a YouTube
video that I posted to my YouTube
channel using photo booth in
2006 it
is absolutely
unhinged
oh my goodness I think that's probably
the last time I use photo booth now that
we've tested out some very simple things
let's go in and see what it's like to
Video Edit on the new M3 iMac so I've
got all of this AK footage we're going
to drag it into the library and here it
is so I'm going to take all of these and
I'm just going to pop them in the
timeline look at that look at that fast
it was like nothing
smooth like butter now none of this has
been converted to progr this is right
off the Sony cameras so this is just
it's just running look at this here we
go here we go little edit here ooh yeah
look little camera move we'll take that
one that's nice that's a nice shot right
there we like
that great looks good maybe add a little
effect or something on here let's see
what we got whoa Moody I know what this
needs night
vision let's try a little stabilization
on this shot
here so there's wow that's it's pretty
stable compared to what we had that's
nice too so obviously my first initial
editing test everything is running super
smooth super fast am I surprised no I'm
absolutely not at all something else new
in macoma is the new game mode so we're
going to test out playing some games
I've got my Spider-Man PS5 controller
connected so one of the games that they
recommend testing was no man's sky so
this is going to be my first time
playing this so I'm really excited so as
you can see right here it says game mode
has turned on this prioritizes the
performance so this will make sure that
everything is optimized for game playing
it also sounds really
great supp assistance
[Music]
activated
system
us initiation sequence
complete all right here we
go so far it's running pretty smooth I
mean I've got zero complaints other than
I wish I had more time to play video
games so I really want to continue
playing this this is actually really fun
I can't believe I've never played this
before so I'm really excited that I can
now play this on my Mac so I will be
sure to install this on my MacBook so
I'll be able to take it with me on the
go so now let's move on to the M3 Max
MacBook Pro onto my editing station I
have this entire desk all set up just
how I like it so I'm basically going to
be swapping my 14-in for the 16in and
I'll show you guys what we've got so
this is my full setup and I'm so excited
because my previous Mac I had completely
maxed out the amount of peripherals that
I could have hooked up and I just now
hooked up an additional 2 tbte solid
state drive and it worked so I'm so
excited that I can now take this setup
up a notch so I have two pro display XDS
one Studio display display also hooked
up I have a bunch of storage options now
I have a Thunder Bay Flex which I use
for all of my backup files and then
hooked up to that I have a 16 TB drive I
have an OWC stack that I use for some
additional USBC ports I have another 2
TB drive that I was using to transfer
some files back and forth and I also
have this OWC Thunderbolt dock which I
have a bunch of things also hooked up to
I've got my gen Lex speakers hooked up
to the ape Symphony there is so much
stuff plugged into this computer and
it's wild because I was running this all
off of that tiny little 14in but now
thanks to the new M3 Max I can hook up
more things to it which is just what I
need you can see I have the MacBook
plugged in right here and I not even
it's not even open cuz I have all of
these displays hooked up to it so let's
get into some editing I already have a
library here that I have prepped with
some 8K footage direct from the Sony
camera and also 8K prores so I made a
little prores timeline here with nine
streams of AK so we're going to play
this really quick
and here it is it's running I'm going to
actually switch this to better quality
and let's pop this open and you can take
a look and see what it looks like
everything is running perfectly smooth
now when I made this timeline initially
I did pop all of this footage in
directly from camera now this timeline
is straight from Sony A1 nothing has
been converted and at first it was a
little bit laggy but now everything is
all rendered in and this is also running
perfectly smooth in better quality we
have no drop frames no stuttering I mean
this is so exciting this current
configuration of the M3 Pro Max MacBook
Pro that I'm using actually has less Ram
than my day-to-day M2 Max MacBook that
I've been using for the past year this
one has 48 and my previous version had
64 so even with less Ram this is running
really smoothly I'm pretty happy with my
editing test let's move on to some
photos shall we all right let's just
open up up regular
Lightroom so as you can see it loaded up
super quick and it pulled up all of
these images that I've already taken
which is very exciting cuz these are
some nice new ones let's go in and edit
um this one from the iPhone 15 shoot in
Catalina so let's up the exposure a
little let's turn down those highlights
let's go this actually let's turn that
down a little bit here we go here we
go up the shadow
give me that give me that saturation
beautiful oh that's great that's really
lovely now let's take this into
Photoshop and this should automatically
open up Photoshop as you can see here
it's there we go there we go super fast
nice okay I kind of want to make this a
little bit taller here so let's see if I
can get generative AI to fill in the
rest of this image for me now the
generative Ai and Photoshop does go to
the cloud so it doesn't really matter
how fast or slow your computer is it
really more depends on your internet
speed and that looks great let's maybe
let's see what it can come up with on
the other
side okay well it kind of gave me a very
interesting watch here maybe there's a
oh that's
nice there that's
perfect love it so I'm pretty happy with
how this all turned out everything has
been working really well now let's move
on to gaming on the MacBook Pro here we
go now I I know I've already played this
before but I don't remember I think I
had to put the baby to sleep okay we got
to go upstairs put the baby to sleep now
the one thing that I've already noticed
is this is running super smooth now
let's remember this is running off of a
Macbook and I have three displays hooked
up to it plus all of these other
accessories sh they're there it's like I
said to your mom that book's too scary
for you oh so scary I don't remember
which one is your oh no where's your
bedroom almost there honey yeah this
looks like your slob room look at all
your toys you're too young to even play
with any toys like you just eat and
stuff I'll be right downstairs Daddy
won't let those weird fairy tale
monsters get
you all right wife where's my meal is
she okay sleeping like a like a
baby so I skipped a few I skipped ahead
and we've clearly are now in some sort
of a
disaster things have expon eventally
escalated Jesus all right so for my
gaming test everything seems to be
running really smoothly also haven't
really experienced any drop frames so
it's no surprise everything is running
smooth everything's running fast I mean
at this point these computers are
getting so good that no matter what you
throw at it it's just going to work now
if you do have an M1 or an M2 computer I
really do feel like it's not necessary
to upgrade to an M3 but you really will
see the jump in performance if you do
have an M1 and more specifically an
Intel Mac if you have an Intel Mac and
you even upgrade to an M1 the
performance increase is going to just
blow your mind so this is kind of a
first look here with the new M3 lineup
and I cannot wait to further test these
out I personally ordered the 14-in
MacBook Pro with the pro Max no I just
keep calling it pro Max M3 Max but like
they have like Pro Max like it just it
just you know if I say PR Max you know
what I mean just we're just going to go
with it if you guys want to watch some
more videos I will put them here on the
end screen and if you enjoyed this video
be sure to like it and leave me some
comments below and let me know what you
think of this new lineup what computer
do you have do you have an Intel or you
upgrading let me know I would love to
hear it and I will see you guys in the
next video bye